feels like the district have style but
no money whereas people in the capital
have money but no style I wanted this
time around to show that District 12
besides the coal mining area that they
have this really you know like a
Heritage of dance and singing and
celebration before the capital has had
their hands so controlling them so I
kind of flipped it this time around and
I went with more color and patterns in
the district and kind of went with more
of what was the nature and environment
around them
and then in the capital made them much
more controlled and classic and
contained whereas in the earlier films
it's more colorful in the capital so I
kind of wanted to flip that around this
time so that we could show that the
districts have all this life and this
happiness and it's really the capital
that people are living under the thumb
of the government